hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester being played
in London the London chess classic do
not mistake it for the London chest
classic feet I opened because that's a
different tournament and I forgot to
mention in the previous video well I
didn't forget I just I thought about
mentioning it but I don't know maybe I
thought that pretty much everyone reads
the description or or something like
that but regardless the way this
tournament now works is that first
eleven is playing against the dink and
Magnus is playing against MVL first they
play to classical games then they play
to rapid games and then they play for
blitz games and then they play against
each other and well you get six points
for a win in the classical time format
so winning in classical is just huge you
get four points for winning in the rapid
section and only two points for winning
in the blitz so if you can get a win in
the classical that's just awesome so
we've seen the game yesterday between
MBL and Magnus it was a well it was just
a brutal game no one should be you know
forced to play positions like that if
not voluntarily yeah and now we're gonna
check out eleven versus dink
so without further ado eleven opens with
d4 with Knight to f6 binding c4 sorry
about that we have E six Knight to f3
and d5 so again the Queens gambit
declined is on the board with Knight to
c3 and now see 5c chapters on d5 we have
Knight captures on d5 and g3 11 now
prepares the V and kept his light square
bishop and ding uses this opportunity to
pretty much trade everything with Knight
captures and c3b captures C capture Sun
d4 seek after sandy 4 and now Bishop to
b4 check I'm going for more trades so he
can just castle to safety with Bishop to
d2 Bishop captures with Queen captures
and then out b6 preparing to fianchetto
the light square bishop so you can
counter white's light square bishop with
the ship to g2 by 11 and now Bishop to
b7 both players Castle with castles
castles and now if you look at the look
at the position being
can be very happy he pretty much well he
definitely equalized with black one
thing white will have that black doesn't
is if for example F 3 and E for our
plate then white will have a huge wealth
central control here so that that goes
for him but other than that black should
be fine black has a two-to-one advantage
on the queenside which which can be
utilized you know far along in the
endgame if we reach that so rook F to
see one by one not going rook a to see
one so obviously this rook is staying on
the a file probably to push a four a
five with Knight to d7 now preparing to
bring the rook into the game and here
there are a couple of known moves rook
the c2 is a non move which prepares the
doubling of rooks on the C file Quintus
e3 is a non move and a4 is a known which
makes sense as the rook is on a one now
but here we have Queen to d3 the Queen
can now support the advancement of the
pawn to e4 but also it brings some
poison to the position for example if
black isn't careful if you play a slow
move something like a six so let's say
then Knight the g5 gives white huge
advantage because you're already
threatening mate and you're threatening
to pick up the bishop on b7 so black
will have to capture the night after
Bishop captures here you attack the rook
once the rook moves you're gonna pick up
the a6 pawn or well there's no or you're
just gonna pick up the pawn as well and
you will enjoy a much better position as
the light square bishop is now a monster
so after Queen to d3 which is a new move
so as I move 14 we have a completely new
game now we have Knights to f6 ding says
ok I'm just defending the h7 pawn so now
you don't have any 95 tricks we have
nice to e5 by 11 and now Bishop captures
and g2 with keen captures and Queen to
d5 with check for the moment not
allowing e4 but 11 plays f3 and the next
movie is going to play E for we look at
the c8 now offering a trade of rooks
along the C file and E for now and here
after the Queen moves we have Queen to
b7
you can see that white now has great
control of the center so this is a small
plus that Levin has with Queen to a3 now
putting
pressure on the a 7-point but also if
for example the rook moves from from f8
and if the Queen no longer controls the
the seven friend maybe the Queen can
infiltrate blacks position with queenie
seventh and maybe f7 can be a target
it's a it's a good square for the Queen
so H five biding he doesn't want to have
any back rank issues once he develops
the rook so the King can now go to h7 if
needed with h4 why does the same now h3
will be a nice safety square for the
white king with rook F to d8 and now the
e the d4 pawn is under attack so here we
have trade we have rook captures here or
you could defend it with Queen to be two
but 11 decides to do it this way
rook captures and see it with rook
captures and see it and rook the c1
offering a trade of another pair of
rooks and here we have looked a c7
preparing Quinta CH to create more
pressure along the sefa but also if y
doesn't react it's just a very useful
piece to have on the seventh rank we've
looked the c3 by eleven now he can also
do the same you can go Queen c1 and have
a lot of pressure along the C file Queen
to c8 now threatening to pick up the
rook and here is where we reach well
almost reach the position from the
thumbnail here xi can choose a well
basically a few different moves well
first let's let's check what happens if
rook captures on c7 if rook captures and
Queen captures then we've just traded
even more material and now let's say
King F do you want to get your king over
here to not allow any checks along the
second rank and then you will basically
have the black Queen forced to stay on
the seventh rank if you don't want to
allow something like Queen to e7 so here
black would go for a series of checks
Quincy to check in III Queen g2 now
allowing Quinta East seven and here it's
basically a forced to draw after a long
series of checks by black when you want
check King to d3 you're gonna go Queen
to f1 check King c2 you're gonna try and
hide but you will fail Queen e2 check
King goes to C three Queen III checking
goes to C four and now Queen back to e2
with check and now whatever you do o is
a King b3 Quinta III check you're gonna
go back in C for Queen e2
if he tries marching of the board you
could you could you will very easily get
to checkmate it if you if you get in the
reach of the black pawns so not
something you want to do so this rook
captures on c7 is possible but like the
title suggests 11 chooses the absolute
coolest way to do the to do what needs
to be done he plays Queen captures on a
7 and now well obviously he's offering a
whole rope thing so dink can either
choose to grab the look or Queen rook
captures Queen so let's see what happens
if you just trade down if rook captures
Queen and rook capture screen with check
with King to h7 and here just a 4 and
believe it or not White has a completely
winning endgame here one such example
will be for example if you go for rook
captures on a for you you want to grab
some points here it will not work
because now just Knight captures on f7
and now after look after sandy 4 you're
gonna get rook h8 check King g6 and not
Knight to e5 is made because the points
very conveniently prevent the black King
from going down the board the night
covers f7 and the rook of course
controls the h-file so the King has
nowhere to go
so after this King to h7 and a 4 you
can't really go pawn grabbing now you're
gonna have to play something else
g6 makes some room for the king but now
rook the c6 again you cannot go after
the pawn because why - just repeats
grabs the f7 pawn and then black is just
in trouble so you're gonna have to
defend it and now d5 is deadly because
you will create a very strong passed
pawn a black cannot capture because the
night falls if you go Knight d7 the
Knight captures on f7 so let's say night
the ea8 but then just d6 and white is
completely winning here this square is
protected the squares protected by the
nitro just gonna push it to victory so
that being said after Queen captures on
a7 a very interesting move they just
decided to capture the roof so rook
captures on c3 but now 11 gets Queen
captures on f7 width check we have King
to h7 and now Queen to g6 check with
King to g8 Queen to f7 check King to h7
Queen g6 check and King to g8
and it was in this position unmoved 28
that the players agreed to a draw
because 11 is done rook and there is no
way to continue the attack with white
and if we're not careful
black will black only needs a move to
consolidate and then you were you're
just dead lost because you're down a
hole rook so both of the both of the
games in round 1 end in a draw today
they will switch piece cars and then mvl
will have the white pieces and also Dean
will have the white pieces so we'll see
what's going to happen it's not as wild
as the game between
MBL and Magnus but that that was a night
or so every everytime mvl plays the
night off it's just completely insane
insane stuff and here Levin chose the
the appropriate way to treat the
position he was never in trouble
it was always black who could make a
mistake so that's what 11 was hoping for
but in the end like I said you win 6
points for winning a classical game but
it also means you are down six points if
your opponent wins wins the classical
game so you don't want to overstep you
know so the the correct approach 411 way
to the white piece we'll see how he does
today with with the black pieces so
that's pretty much it for this game so I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Phillip Schweitzer Steve Foster
and if run Hajjaj for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester finals continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
when we finish with the current events
in the world we are starting our next
big saga thank you all I will see Asian
and have an excellent rest of your day